[Music]
she isn't real but I'll just have to
deal
she's just an app on my iPhone fun
gee Josh you find she's so reliable
she'll never leave
you told me she couldn't love that way
[Music]
you said that you can't stay
she doesn't even have a beating heart
and it's just tears
baby
[Music]
and
don't leave
[Music]
Siri how do I know it seems to me is
just a feeling this could never
I know
[Music]
I know is what you told me Justine
Siri can you
sorry I don't understand Siri can you
tell me how to love
[Music]
you know my name
that's what you told me anyway
so okay
she knows the
[Music]
she tries to comprehend
to make yourself understand love
justine I am sorry but I cannot
[Music]